i am currently rated let's see i am
currently rated
13.98 so we're up to a pretty high
rating
uh and this is where it kind of starts
getting more fun for certain players
[Music]
and we're playing i think our first
1500. okay
so uh in the last couple of games we've
been playing the sicilian accelerated
dragon
which is where blackfian tattoo is the
bishop
and i highly recommend the accelerated
for people in the 12 1300
range who are looking to learn a new
opening uh because it's it's rel
it's quite approachable uh it's easy to
learn and it can give you
very good positions if white doesn't
know what to do so this move c3 is
already kind of a mistake because
it it obstructs that square from the
knight
and now the knight will have no good
square so we should simply continue
developing here obviously we can't take
the pawn because
there's two defenders and i can't draw
arrows and then two attackers so let's
just continue developing our pieces
um and he goes f3 now this is a very
common mistake we've seen
several people go f3 in these kinds of
positions it looks okay because he
defends the pawn
but we already know that this creates
weaknesses around white's king that we
can exploit
in what way how do we open up the center
here another move that we've seen many
times let me just open the window
how do we open up the center in order to
exploit the weaknesses caused by this
move
we go d5 we go d5 that's also the power
of the sicilian this move is often just
very strong
uh because this square is nicely
supported by what i drew four arrows and
none of them were
the one that i wanted to draw that's a
new world record
okay so d5 um and
he can't keep the center closed he
basically has to take or he can take the
knight we would take with the pawn okay
he tries to keep the center closed
and i'll take this opportunity
wait what happened paragucci thank you
for the sub
okay someone said something funny and i
missed it so in such a position
the concept of keeping the tension is
incredibly important a lot of players
they sort of want to resolve the tension
if there's a lot of pieces hanging in
the air
they want to always make sure that that
tension is resolved
and doesn't exist but sometimes we can
just continue developing
and at the end of the day we're going to
benefit so we can actually win a pawn
here but i want to show this concept
uh in this game and the move that we're
going to play is just castles okay we're
not doing anything we're just developing
and we're letting our opponents be the
one okay so he also castles now it's
time for us to win a pawn
how do we go about winning a pawn
there's two main captures here we can
play d take c4 or knight takes d4 how do
we decide
which one should we do who can tell me
thank you hit stick for the prime
one of these captures wins a pawn
the other does not very good
knight takes d4 wins upon d takes e4
would have allowed the intermediate move
knight takes c6 now we take on e4
exposing
the attack on d4 do we take on d4
immediately we do not
because white's queen defends the pawn
but hey we played the accelerated dragon
and that is exactly why this bishop is
incredibly strong
it comes into the game in many positions
we've won a pawn
that's a pretty good start but obviously
that's not gonna win us the game
we need to continue developing our
pieces uh we haven't completed our
development we still have this bishop
where can this bishop go only one square
and that's e6
it can't go to d7 queen b6 would have
been a good move as well connecting the
rooks
that might be our next move i'm
anticipating probably okay queen c2
the move queen c2 is weird it doesn't
really accomplish anything in fact the
queen is quite vulnerable on the square
can we exploit that vulnerability
through a targeted move what can we do
here we can go rook c8 and we can attack
the queen
that's always a good idea we bring the
rook into the game and we attack a queen
so we do it with tempo
now it's time for us to deploy our other
rook but that's not possible because
well that would be an illegal move rook
fda is not possible because our queen is
there so our task then is to move the
queen onto a square
vacate that square for the rook but we
don't want to move the queen just
anywhere because the queen also fulfills
the crucial duty
of defending the bishop so let's move it
out of the d file that way rook d1
does not actually pin the bishop so so
this move contains a lot of benefits in
addition it kind of attacks b2 okay so
bishop h6 we don't care
because we wanted to do this anyway rook
fda
and now all of our pieces are in the
game our rooks are in open files our
bishops aren't tremendous
squares and our queen is in the game
when that happens
it's like there's a clicking you know
there's a clicking sound everything is
clicked into place
now it's time to nurture the advantage
and and find ways to tighten the screw
then what does that mean what do we do
specifically here
there's a couple of ways to go about
this position one way is to improve
pieces even further
the other way is to identify annoying
pieces
on our opponent's side and eliminate
them and this bishop on h6 kind of
annoys me
uh it annoys me because it it limits the
king it creates
attacking potential and if we trade that
bishop this bishop is kind of
lame now what would be the best way to
trade the bishop it would not actually
be
bishop to g7 because bishop to g7 allows
his bishop to move along this diagonal
bishop to e3 is the move that we're
going to play
the the second reason this move is good
is because if he when he takes the
bishop because he basically has no other
choice
we will take with a queen and that queen
from b6 okay he does have a choice he
can blunder his bishop
uh which is what he did now
we got the best of all worlds what i was
going to say
is that if he takes on e3 we take with
the queen our queen is incredibly well
placed it attacks the bishop on e2 it
pressures the pawn on e4
and all around it just exerts tremendous
pressure in white's position while also
keeping a7 defended that's the ideal
role
for the piece um
and a lot of excuse me let me just take
a sip of water i'm losing my voice
so we could have also exchanged the
queens with a move like queen c6 i was
thinking about that
now a lot of people don't consider this
kind of move because they feel like it
weakens
this diagonal subconsciously oh my god
there's going to be a queen that lands
on g7 with checkmate
but you want to be very realistic and
you want to be very practical
at this level and what that means is
sometimes you want to make a move that
makes you feel uncomfortable if it
accomplishes a very specific aim
and if you're tactically confident then
you're also going to be confident in
your ability
to to make these kinds of moves and and
override your maybe intuitive instincts
that are telling you something is wrong
with the move
uh so anyways we're we're going to take
a closer look at the game
afterward but let's play another one and
then we're going gonna look at games in
batches of two
that's just sparkling water let's go e4
and uh he plays the sicilian now the
opening that we're going to play here
is the c3 sitillion an opening that i
also played
in my childhood as we saw and he
actually finds the correct response he
strikes immediately in the center
the basic idea of the c3 sicilian is of
course to play d4
you're trying to control the center and
you're trying to do so with pawns
and you're trying to do so while
maintaining the general health of the
position and what are the drawbacks
the c3 system the first is that the c3
pawn obstructs as we
saw in the previous game the knight and
the second is that we spend some time
moving our pawns so our opponent does
get a small lead in development which we
need to remedy as early as possible so
let's
try to remedy that by developing our own
pieces okay bishop g4
pins uh the knight on f3 and as we
already know the best way to unpin
is by developing our bishop with bishop
b2
we'll talk about the trade that's an
important point but we will talk about
it
okay so here goes e6 now one of the keys
to understanding the elephant
is also is understanding the knight on
b1 where can this knight on b1
go people look at the knight they think
okay it has to go to d2 but d2 is kind
of lame
because it blocks the bishop and on c1
but the knight actually has a very
interesting maneuver
uh that makes the alpine tick where else
can the knight go
go to a3 what is it doing on a3 didn't
you say knights on the rim are grim well
they are
but that knight is heading to b5 he
stops us but b5 isn't the only square
that i can go
or c4 and now it's actually going to b6
so when you're looking at a piece
remember i talked about kinetic and
potential energy you want to look about
you want to look at
where it's ultimately going not only
where it's currently placed and
that's a very important distinction
because sometimes you look at a piece
and you just dismiss that
piece is terrible but it's actually you
know in the airport waiting for its
connection flight to
freaking venice okay this guy is playing
well
okay how do we continue now believe it
or not we have a chance to increase the
pressure here because
he has not developed his king side so if
we can find a way to like attack
something he'll have a hard time
defending it because he just doesn't
have the forces mobilized he's moved his
queen around
queen a4 would be a good idea but he has
b5 covering it and forking archwing on
the night but you're very close
bishop g5 also doesn't really accomplish
anything because
the pin is not that dangerous but in my
opinion
the only way to actually make a serious
threat here is queen to b3 that's the
move we're going to play
and again after the game i'll explain
this move
more deeply but now we're going to
position this knight on e5 and look how
far this knight has gone it started from
a3 and now it's nicely centralized on e5
so one of the reasons that we okay go c4
which is actually i think good for us
let's keep let's bring the queen back
and one thing that that he's been doing
here is he's really over extending his
pawns
uh and and we're going to exploit that
with a very thematic move first let's
eliminate that annoying bishop
okay now let's try to exploit
this pawn chain now when i say split
this punching i usually mean attacking
the base of the pawn chain
pawn on a6 cannot be attacked b3 would
be attacking the tip of the pawn chain
that would be sort of a conceptual
mistake let's go e4 to try to undermine
this is what undermining is you attack
the base of something
it's like you remove the jenga uh and
the whole it's been
years since i played that game this guy
is actually really really good he's
definitely
well well well over 1400 now let's
position the knight on g5
exposing the attack on his knight second
idea of this move is to position the
bishop on f3 on an open diagonal to
attack the rook
once that rook is attacked it has to
move away from the a-file
look what else is on the afl or rook
r-rook
will potentially be able to land on a6
exerting even more pressure on his
position
let's take it and open the file now
one thing that's important to understand
this phrase the threat is stronger than
its execution
sometimes you don't want to make a move
that looks tempting you want to sort of
keep it in reserve you want to keep it
in reserve and you want to complete your
development first
so that we only play rook a6 when
absolutely necessary so let's deploy our
other pieces our rook
we castled and let's wait for a more
appropriate moment for rook a6
okay he's attacking our pawn let's
defend it
yeah this guy is playing i would say
like a 23 2400 i know
so bishop f4 here would be a very good
move for example
not a 1400 level move okay h694 he
doesn't leave us a choice
bishop takes c4 so right now we're just
recapturing pieces
and um let's see knight f6 okay f5 is
is is a mistake why is a f5 a mistake
can somebody explain
in my opinion of course maybe i'm wrong
but why is this a positional
at least a dubious move positionally
is right so it weakens the pawn on e6
and that pawn is very attackable in fact
we've positioned our rook there
now do you guys remember i said the
threat is stronger than its execution
there's a certain move we did not play
earlier because it wasn't that strong
it's time for that move r-rook is moving
into c6
in order to try to break up the
connection between his queen
and his bishop it's okay to lose
well this guy is uh very very
competitive i'll i'll say that he's
yeah he's extremely underrated knight f6
is a good move
and now we need to decide how to how to
proceed
but we have a well i think we have a
fork we actually have a fork
we have a fork and it's not the most
clear cut of forks but it is a fork that
fork is bishop c6 working his pawn
and his rook um now
one moment okay
so let's see what he does if he goes
rook b8
okay we're going to take the pawnee if
he had done rook b8 we would have taken
e6 now we take this one remember i told
you he weakened his pawn chain well
this is the result of it we finally
managed to exploit it
maybe he's doing a speed run too then
we'd be both doing speed runs
he's making some really good moves and
some not so good moves of course i might
be wrong
um so we will see
he also yeah again people play well i
mean that's just the state of affairs
in chess knight to e4 he's centralizing
his knight
okay i don't like that i find this
knight to be quite annoying can we get
rid of this knight
can we get rid of this knight i mean can
we but but don't even think about
playing f3
without weakening all of these squares
around our king
bishop c6 let's go back to c6 chasing
the knight away
and the move f3 would just create a lot
of weaknesses on the king side that that
would be the issue
primary issue with that move and um
i do have videos like this on youtube
and plenty of them and i'm uploading
more
capablanca loves to lose exactly so
let's see what he ends up doing queenie
2 didn't really
do much oh i guess he wanted to attack
c4 yeah that would have been possible
queen e2 would have been would have been
possible as well uh
to attack the pawn on on c4 but i like
this a little bit more
because by taking the knight we can
stabilize the situation
now he's attacking f2 so let's defend
that with bishop e3
let's let's defend the pawn of bishop e3
now bishop f4 would be a strong move on
his end trying to remove the defender
and he doesn't so hmm
let me think for a second this guy is
definitely making me think
let's bring the queen in let's let's
bring the cavalry in sometimes when
our opponent is applying pressure we
want to bring as many defenders as
possible into the game
and um hopefully this queen is going to
lend enough support to the king
in order to ward off the immediate
threats if he takes the bishop we can
just take with the pawn i realized that
it could be scary to open up the f file
when his rooks are doubled there but
on the other hand r rook defends f1
and the reality is he doesn't have any
entry points he can go to f2 but that
doesn't really threaten anything this is
that emphasis i made on concreteness
this is the emphasis i made on not
falling for the way that something looks
and just assuming that it's dangerous
for example
and this is uh i think a very good
position for us
why not pick the pawn on e6 well that's
our plan that's our plan but
we don't have time for that yet we need
to first attend to our king
yeah rook on a6 is incredibly strong
it's like exerting this pressure on his
position he's also running short of time
okay don't rely too much on heuristics
when you can calculate well queen c
we can still probably take on e6 because
we have two attackers and one defender
okay queen b7 is a good move let's take
on e6 he's going to take on b2
and he's threatening queen f to check
now that's an annoying threat because
that would win the rook
so let's move his his rook away
let's sorry let's move the king he's
going to lose on time
he's going to lose on time again he
played extremely well
by the way our last move sets up a
little battery against the g7 pawn
wow that was a that was a tough game i
think i played quite well
and uh can i can i check his accuracy
sure
i don't think it was absurdly high let
me see
88.3 and ours was 87.7
so yeah i mean he played really well
uh but he made mistakes so
i just think this guy is super
underrated and uh
i don't think he's up to anything yeah
he's better than me exactly
but yeah more accurate than us and i i'm
actually like trying you know i'm
actually trying to find good moves thank
you kanako the squirrel for the friend
appreciate the sub so
i don't know i mean
yeah he was playing defensively and he
he found some obvious moves he also
found some good moves
um but it is what it is uh anyways
he he took a little bit too long uh
finding these moves
okay um so let's go over the two games
and then we will continue
now basically in this first game in the
accelerated dragon
the move f3 is very typical uh i've seen
several people actually do this precise
thing they'll play c3 to support the
knight
and then they'll play f3 to support the
pawn and both of these moves are bad
uh and as i explained the reason c3 is
bad is because it
takes the c3 square away from the
knights and that is
that is just not good uh you want to
develop that knight to c3 so
usually people just play knight c3 and
bishop e3 to defend the knight
and there is a checklist that you want
to go through when you feel like one of
your pieces
is going to be attacked there are
several ways
you can defend against an attack one is
to move a piece from a square
but that can be bad because that doesn't
develop anything
but when we want to make sure of is that
when you're defending a piece with a
pawn
you're not also taking away crucial
squares from your other pieces or you're
not weakening your position
so this is a form of tunnel vision at
like a 1500 level
as you guys know from my sessions with
charlie i've defined this term tunnel
vision
um to mean over emphasis on a particular
factor of the position in that like a
beginner level
beginner beginner tunnel vision usually
results in like a queen blunder like you
look at one side of the board and you'll
forget about the other side of the board
and
blunder the queen 1500s don't tend to do
that but what fifteen hundred's tend to
do
is they'll make a move that has a very
specific purpose such as defending a
pawn or a piece
they will forget that that move also
contains very significant long-term
drawbacks
how did i know to pull the trigger well
because he played f3 and opened up his
position we go d5
here we just castle and that can be the
solution to a lot of problems you don't
need to force anything
i don't like the movie 5. this is a move
a lot of people would play
let me explain why exactly i think this
is a mistake
there are several reasons the first is
that it helps him untangle his pieces
it's actually a good thing for him to
trade knights because
this knight on d4 as we saw in the game
is actually vulnerable
second is that it blocks the bishop i
hate this i hate the fact that it blocks
the bishop because the bishop
this position is is is the most
important piece so it's the same exact
thing you want to make sure that a move
which seems tempting
doesn't contain more drawbacks than
strength so we castle
and now we take the pieces in the right
order if we had taken on e4
first he could have taken the knight
first so always check for in between
moves
don't just assume that he's going to
recapture the same piece or pawn
and now once he captures his knight
defends the pawn safely
so knight takes d4 is the reason
it's the reason why we played this move
and then this move opening up
the attack on the pawn on d4 the rest is
very simple we take the pawn
we complete our development we attack
the queen we bring our own queen out we
activate the rook
now we trade his best piece the concept
of looking for your opponent's best
piece and trading it
uh is i would say
well let me and okay if people are like
taking notes
or something you know this is like my
chest philosophy so
i can formulate positional chests right
people hear the term thank you calacas
for the tier one
people hear the term positional chess
and they freak out all traditional gm's
jams positional chess only for gms
but the reality is positional chess
itself is a simpler concept than people
realize
and in my opinion if i had to define
positional chess in
three separate concepts they would be
the following
one improving the placement of your own
pieces
two trading good pieces for bad pieces
or bad pieces for good pieces
uh either your bad piece for your
opponent's good piece
or well i guess that's the only good way
to do it but your opponent could also be
trading his good piece for your
his bad piece for your good piece and
then the third method is uh of course
provoking weaknesses okay provoking
weaknesses in your opponent's territory
so improving provoking and trading
i think that these now this is not the
extent of it but these are the bases
the three bases of sort of positional
chess
and doing either of those things isn't
that hard per se observing making the
right observations that lead to those
things
aren't necessarily that difficult and
and
i think some people need to get over
their fear of positional chess and start
thinking like that
so let me give you an example of where
things can get a little bit hard and
people often hear the term positional
chess and tactics overlap
what does that mean what does it mean
for positional chess and tactics to
overlap and
why can that make something more
difficult
let me give a good example before we
move on to the speed run
and then we will look at the second game
and then we will move on
so please give me a second because i
also need to keep opening chess space
and my game collection to be able to
pull up
uh pertinent examples from the games
under this is from the under 16 or sorry
under 14 world championship
in vietnam so men will be happy i'm
showing this game
and i won this game in the end but but
benjamin played a very instructive move
here
in the following position okay
so we are taking the side of benjamin
here
um and
um it is blocked to move in this
position
now first of all when you look at this
end game
uh who is better here like what is the
snapshot
picture that you get who is and thank
you dealer citizens thank you guys for
all the compliments i really appreciate
it this this keeps me going and
uh this is awesome so what exactly why
is white better
yeah white is better what is better for
two very specific
for three very specific reasons reason
number one
is the fact that black is a very bad
backward pawn
this backward pawn can be attacked if
white puts like if i put my queen on f3
reason number two as many of you guys
are pointing out is
the disparity in the position of the
knights black's night is terrible
white's night is amazing
does anybody see reason number three
this is a pretty nice
question i'll give you guys a hint
reason number three
is related to the fact that this is an
endgame there's something you need to
look for
when you're in an end game not really
discovery ideas i'm not sure what you're
referring to exactly
it's not the king placement white's king
being open is something that is in
black's favor
so outside passpon yes a couple of you
guys are noticing this
white has the idea potentially of
creating the outside
pass pawn that is the pass pawn that is
furthest from all the other pawns
with the move h4 potentially why would
this be important because if we have a
pawn end game
the side that could create the outside
passer usually holds pretty big
advantage
but black has a lot of problems on his
hands and benjamin found the way to
solve them
black to play and make the most out of
this difficult situation
black to play and make the most out of
this difficult situation he found a very
nice
what i would call a positional tactic
and some of you are pointing it out
already i want to give people
a moment to think about it so
the move f5 i can just play e takes f5
because
my queen is also reinforcing the knight
so
undermining the knight is a good idea
but that's not quite going to cut it
yes so as many of you are pointing out
the move is 97. doesn't this blunder
a knight it does not this is where the
tactical element comes in i have to take
or he takes my knight check trading the
bad knight for the good night
four king queen takes c7 we have a pawn
we have a queen end game
and in the queen end game the fact that
my king is very weak should give black
enough to make a draw i managed to win
this game i
kind of finagled my way into creating a
past pawn
uh but basically this is a very simple
example
of trading a uh bad piece for a good
piece
and uh i can give you a million of these
examples this is positional chess that's
all there is to it
it's not that complicated per se but uh
that's why it's very important to have
this kind of practice now we had two
donations that i
failed to recognize as i was talking hit
stick donated five dollars
saying incredibly informative easily
digestible lessons
i look forward to seeing more of your
amazing content thank you thank you so
much
and astro darwin donated ten dollars
just a couple seconds ago thanks for
doing this this is the right speed
very happy to hear that thanks to both
of you for the
uh for the incredible generosity
uh what if i had played 93 preserving
the knights well
it's important to recognize that now
white's knight is no longer good
and also i drop either of these pawns so
this is basically not a good thing i can
find
if you guys want another good example
let's just do one more example of this
because this is very important for a lot
of people to kind of master
the i guess the art of of sort of
automatically detecting what your worst
place pieces and then trading it
for one of your opponents better pieces
or just improving it in general
and a lot of maneuvers can be
demystified through the lens
of positional thinking through the lens
of these one of these three things
this is a position that i had
when i was already at gm 2014
and in this position i had just won a
piece but my opponent attempted to win
the piece back
with the move f6 and uh
in this position i found a very strong
move
but this move is very hard to find
unless you specifically try to
understand
the drawback of the move f6 like when we
look at the move f6 we understand its
strengths because its strengths are very
obvious it forks the bishop in the night
its drawbacks are much harder to sort of
recognize but you guys are on the money
right now people are on a roll
i'll give you guys a couple seconds to
think about this
bishop e2 is correct very nice bishop b2
basically going to c4 the move f6
exposes the diagonal
the queen and the king are on the same
diagonal therefore you should always be
thinking about pins
if you have a bishop my opponent has to
cover this diagonal with e6
let's apply the same thinking i played
bishop c4 queen d6
what is the drawback of the movie 6 very
specifically and how does white exploit
it
what do we do in this position in order
to keep the extra piece
yeah but i know like maybe i wouldn't
see this in blitz either but like now
we're taking a closer look at these
games
so hopefully people can start like
thinking about this kind of stuff
so what is the drawback of the movie six
yeah g4 is correct and you're just
trapping the bishop so e6 covers the
bishop's escape route
back to d7 the bishop is now trapped
i preserved my extra piece and my
opponent resigned so very very simple
stuff
but this illustrates the importance and
i include this under the realm of
positional chess
detecting the drawbacks of your
opponent's move positional thinking the
drawbacks are just more subtle
you know a tactical drawback could be
something like weakening the king
positional drawback could be more subtle
such as exposing i guess it's
somewhere in between exposing a diagonal
in which both the queen and the king are
located
okay what if he didn't play e6 well
there's just no other way to defend
against bishop c4
if he plays king h8 then this is just
absolutely crushing
so anyways let's go back to the speeder
and we have one more game to quickly
look at
before we move on and that is that very
tightly contested game in the
allopancillion thank you binary steen
for the tier one
now basically okay so in the beginning
we played the mainline allopin now my
opponent correctly did not capture on d4
and this again relates to the concept of
not of keeping the tension because this
now creates
uh the c3 square for the knight
therefore you want to keep these pawns
here so that my c3 pawn stops the knight
from developing
and so the knight has to seek alternate
arrangements which it does
queen diet is theory and now the move
queen b3 i want to explain this move and
then i want to move on
now what is the purpose of provoking b5
and to explain this i want to share
another element of my chest philosophy
which is that uh people misunderstand
the concept of pawns moving forward
so this might be a little bit this might
sound a little arrogant like i know
everything i know very little so take
this with a grain of salt my
views might change but basically
whenever someone moves a pawn
by definition weaknesses are created in
the position because pawns don't move
backwards so squares that were formally
controlled by pawns
are no longer controlled uh by
by any piece oh my
this was the missing piece this was the
missing
piece and he has arrived gem jam taco
with 10 gifted
subs oh my
okay i'm done i'm i'm walking away
goodbye guys
i'm spilling more tea and i'm walking
away
this 10 000 bits
yeah the context gem jam look at the sub
count
earlier today we had i don't even know
how to explain the stream
and this was the missing piece oh my
10 subs followed by 10 000 bits
what is this 3160
this is this is on thanks for the fats
and gifts look at the sub
look at the bit leaderboard and the the
sub leaderboard
it's unbelievable
unbelievable thank you thank you
jam jim logic gifted 150 this will not
be my last speeder and i have a feeling
it won't be
but before i was rudely interrupted by
gem jim
um i was just kidding thank you so much
i was sharing why b5 is a bad move
so i was saying that by definition when
you move upon
you create weaknesses left behind like
these squares
c6 is no longer controlled but in
addition the pawns themselves
become more vulnerable okay and if you
think about it
uh if you're playing capture the flag i
love capture the flag
um i don't know about you guys okay
sorry this makes me miss
six capture the flag in sixth grade that
is one of the few games that i'm good at
if you're playing capture the flag you
know those guys who always jump across
the fence and then jump immediately back
i was one of those people
um you know you know what i'm talking
about it's a bit of a
abstruse reference but you can think of
chess as like a game of capture the flag
the moment you cross the horizon
you can be tart you can be targeted by
the opponent and the same goes for pawns
as soon as the pawns move away from
their
from their starting positions they
become more vulnerable because it is
more difficult to defend them with
pieces
if you think about it black could have
gone queen c7 here and very easily
protected the pawn he can protect it
also even with rook a7
but if you fast forward to the move a4
um it's very difficult to protect this
pawn this pawn is
outside the range of black's pieces and
so like it's hard to just it's hard to
support it because now the rook on it is
also hanging the same goes for the c4
pawn if we play b3
we undermine the pawn and so this entire
campaign was to provoke his pawns into
moving forward
when people look at pawns moving forward
they assume oh
you know the opponent is grabbing space
like it's it's bad for us
but you should really be careful about
how you understand uh the movement of
puns
because oftentimes it creates more
weaknesses
uh than than then i guess more harm than
good is done
okay so nanuka is asking could we have
taken c4
uh we could have tried but in this
position i think
despite the fact that it is a fork black
can defend against both threats with
knight bd7
um so he should probably i mean i'm not
sure where he made his exact mistakes
i think he should probably go queen c7
here i think b5 actually wasn't
inaccuracy
uh and well the rest is pretty smooth i
mean knight g5 bishop f3 activating the
bishop
and our moves are relatively intuitive
it's just that he played very well
uh but i think i largely outplayed him
can't you take on v7 after queen c7
uh maybe i actually missed something
let's see oh that's a great idea
zazy but it doesn't work because the
bishop guards d6 so you wanted to do
this i think
but unfortunately bishop takes d6 um
and that's a great idea though good
tactical recognition that means you're
you're you're making progress maybe
bishop f4
is actually interesting distracting the
queen and taking on you know maybe
blackwise queen e4 this is complicated
uh but uh long story short that is
the reason that i played queen v3
sometimes provoking pawn moves is
actually a really good thing
okay let's play a couple more and we're
going to wrap up soon i have to sleep
pretty early if he goes queen c8 by the
way there's knight p6 forking
the queen and the rook
[Music]
you